[Musique]
un masque de bruits de coups de couteau utilise la première
chose est au lieu de ne pas avoir fait de
questions échappées ma mata est venue de loin pour
honorer la mémoire de ses enfants elle est
à gimmick de mana wan dans le centre du
québec récemment elle a partagé son histoire
avec nous  Akiyama
pense que c'est à nouveau une sorte de regard ensemble
que vous faites tous super bien
l'année prochaine pensez à ce jour-là, c'était en
1971, la dernière fois qu'elle les verrait,
le médecin a dit à Martha que ses jumeaux étaient
morts mais elle n'a jamais vu leur corps se
couper c'est un  miracle dans un certificat
ils m'ont dit et martelé la
critique de Canasta un doute se pose
à sa demande nous avons trouvé les
documents ainsi que le rapport d'autopsie
exposent sont ils ohms
selon nos recherches ses jumeaux
auraient été enterrés ici à Juliette dans
une commune  tombe pour les corps non réclamés mais
vous êtes surpris que
Martha reste sceptique lire Park est
un autre bébé loriana
aurait été enterré ici en 1973 mais
ses sœurs sont tout aussi sceptiques si un
signal l'argent une âme  pourtant Paul se
souvient de sa belle-famille épreuve le Piranha
au geai bleu le revenu alemana veut seulement la
voir ressentir vous remarquez un
téléphone de la carrière
Laurie et Allah être tué Laura ouais
l'amour parental et la ville ils reviennent tout de
suite 200 kilomètres en hydravion ils sont
abasourdis  par ce qu'ils découvrent
non le non-facteur Luca loriana Gallardo
valeriano vient de sortir du Seigneur jamais
éclat de guerre ou pas Piazza masse sur l'
atrophie la personne à dire oh oui vous
recevrez quelle redevance PA raffermissant le cercle
à ce jour aimer et j'ai toujours listé  dans
le registre des moteurs de statut a été
vivant mais est-ce suffisant pour interroger
suffisamment
donc le certificat de décès à côté de notre
panier de cartes scientifiques Emma regarde c'est avec
l'histoire d'Alice que nous commençons à
comprendre leur méfiance a soutenu nos
culs J'adore Alice avait besoin d'une
chirurgie de la hanche elle était  envoyée seule à l'
hôpital de Joliet pour la première fois les parents d'Alice
avaient accepté de la laisser à
Joliet pour se faire soigner de ne pas l'
abandonner à une autre famille
marbury  mon Mario Antonov semi-célèbre
rappeur à Sonora
Alice a été renvoyé mais beaucoup d'autres ont
disparu envoyés à l'hôpital pour des soins
pour disparaître pendant des années certains pour
toujours c'est ainsi que Diane a disparu pendant des années
La famille Parata Kamek nous a invités dans leur
camp pour nous raconter son histoire mon amour  était de
tous les nœuds sur les secondes ce n'est pas
le précipice une malédiction sur bébé ne sois pas
mon garçon dois voir plus comme tu sais l'
économie la plus commune et Oh Joel ils ont
répondu au panier final Subhan Allah
satanique Hamas sur le bébé fenouil mon comment voyez-
vous  demande et Ivo être totalement
allergique non une a été évacuée sans sa
mère comme c'était la norme à l'époque shyam
pneumonie qui l'obligeait à rester à l'
hôpital dans ce costume mais ensuite elle a
disparu avec une famille blanche
sans le consentement de ses parents sur un
service de documents de voyage  socio généralement par PA
plus mod alpha je pose des questions sur D
para dejar monsieur dr.  Muhammad voyageur
docume un souffle colada Sania docume le
manquer
heureusement avec un désastre pour cactus x1 II
suppose que s'offrir un visa Nisa dr.  Marla a des
endroits pour vous virer il
y a un messager mais mec c'est une
expérience rare capitate merci monsieur
vous connaissez la société le contactez moi él a la
isla espiritu Road reservoir arcades
aleppo Venetian and facade Nepal B la
ceremonia de por nada no virus the tape
are the chef  de Partie QC bass ke
Rizzo TV navire un plan quotidien Katya
balasana tu appartiens à fils mère pour
trois plats oh mec on a du mal à
imaginer l'isolement de ces
communautés et les
semi-nomades des années 70 vivant une partie de l'année dans des
tentes sous des terrains de chasse les
le reste dans des cabines sans électricité
ni téléphone se rendre à la ville la plus proche
signifiait souvent des jours de canoë ou de portage
jusqu'à la ligne de train qui les
amènerait à vous laisser Aramis quand Alice
retournait à l'hôpital pour donner naissance
à ses autres enfants elle
interrogeait toujours les infirmières sur  Diane en haute
énergie et
eau bonne promenade ce que je comprends
séparément
ce message a été répété par un homme blanc
qui possédait le seul téléphone en ville à venir
sur notre  imaginez mes schémas de pieds, elle est
ce sont des adeptes de
la cuvée suprême de la féminité et de tous les
préparateurs de marqueurs persica qui Calipari publicisent
tous les courants politiques récents et
je pense que Oh a été embauchée dans les années 70 pour
établir des services sociaux dans la marijuana,
elle a été témoin de la  mentalité dans les
hôpitaux au moment où il a acheté c3
surprenez-moi au style safari surprenez-moi
un autre scanner heureusement une grande
supervision ou directement la plupart des oculomoteurs
connaissent quelqu'un à qui ils peuvent faire c'est bon
n'en a jamais assez un blog sur le NR une
certaine chose c'est Vegas à travers le
Derek  et je trouve que cela arrive quand de
protección compte chaque sénat à l'arène
programme d'incendie chercheur de requin sauce Lehrer un
gros vrai est un avis Vita
se la faccia sur le jardin Liepaja
médecin sur la pilule non Tom Murray pur
busca est directeur des
études autochtones à l'université  de Montréal pour
super prolonger je verrai Aviva
performer à la condition vraie toujours
sujette seulement malade donc le garçon sur la
marge bénéficiaire mais n'est pas f  ou nous c'est vraiment
mérité promenade tu prends sur le do do
généralement montre essai compliqué là-bas
sur la logistique les gens à travers le
système lézard la fatigue et l'asie un kebab
fait monsieur en attique faire des
communautés les enfants sont partout
jouant leurs jeux en riant ceux
qui ont disparu  ou pas oubliés
mais jusqu'à présent leurs parents ont versé
leurs larmes en silence
il n'y a pas une communauté Atacama pas
une famille épargnée par la perte d'un
enfant
Viet opechee quand Montes XI ou mana
Wan on n'a qu'à s'étendre près et un
micro pour entendre  les histoires d'
enfants volés comme le frère de Suzanne qui a
disparu de l'hôpital dans un désordre
et a été retrouvé des années plus tard
malheureusement une catastrophe en
saison se souvient du retour de son frère
beaucoup quotidiennement appeler une autre famille une autre
disparition en réponse à l'enlèvement de
sa sœur Piatt est né en laisse malade
avec le cordon autour du cou,
elle avait besoin de soins mais surprise quand son
père est allé lui rendre visite à l'hôpital, elle
avait  disparu au delà de la politique sno-med en
disant viens tonton je garde un peu
plus de tarte ils l'ont trouvé avec une
famille d'accueil à 15 kilomètres à sabah man
policy law alors tu te vois au SEMA mon
portable
l'enfant a ensuite été envoyé dans un hôpital à
Montréal
elle  les parents ont réussi à lui rendre visite jusqu'à l'
âge de deux ans
mais comme ils reviennent un jour le
prêtre attendait à la gare koala Mauryan
can't Yahoo you translate wrap the crèche
the brakeman maritima my primo pokemon
back military member zzmatt mom eres the
beta parameter Olivarez my  Le
plateau d'Alicia est pareil avec le frère de Jasmine
qui a également été hospitalisé à Montréal
1970 il est décédé plusieurs mois plus tard d'
après l'infirmière qui a qualifié sa
mère de mère de désir vous savez -
stahma ma petite papinek
valeurs de Sara V je suis propriétaire d'une équipe
perspective même demander  si sept chats lys
sont un PR plus beaucoup qui sont les
bienvenus conception secrète solo Frankie idée
vegeta mon avis est un
âge faisant autorité, ce sont les collèges McKee qui les sortent
Kell  y reproduire l'assistante sociale a en
fait trouvé un enfant vivant dont
on a dit aux parents qu'il était mort tout le monde qui
sait être une mémoire permanente ce qu'elle
ne médicamente pas sa mère
philosophiquement
être le producteur des actes pour moi ouais Vicki
Tracy ne ressource pas le sérum d'ammoniaque et la
nature bâclée  le journaliste Tskhinvali Jack lui
montre en personne
pourquoi le ministère des
Affaires indiennes a émis une directive par injustice comme il l'a
fait avec la directive sur les pensionnats,
une préoccupation particulière n'est pas pour le
dr.  nosik en détention provisoire seule communauté les
limites de sipper sont le travail ou socio tous un
missionnaire
ELISA Jean est mille yens oui c'est
Diane a retrouvé sa famille à l'
adolescence lors de leur première rencontre Diane
découvre une flopée de frères et sœurs un jumeau
élevé pour réserver dans la langue
inconnu de Diane s'il vous plaît une
jeune famille égoïste autruche que
vous avez sélectionnée pour apparaître sur YouTube:
P&V connaît ces histoires d'
enfants volés chasser les familles artic émiques les
dossiers médicaux que nous avons trouvés ont peu de
poids contre l'espoir que les familles
ont entretenu au fil des ans
les célébrités et l'alcool  oh pauvre cher
lavage Missoni Interceptor suivez exacta
ma le paradis loriana la vérité sur
Liliana nous l'avons découverte après cette
visite un témoin qui était présent à l'
époque a confirmé que Liliana n'était pas
enterrée dans la fosse commune comme nous le
croyions mais plutôt dans un champ à côté
du  cimetière comme un chien
[Musique]
toi